you
ladies and gentlemen the President of
the United States
thank you very much please please great
occasion I want to welcome everyone to
the White House we're here today to
announce a vital new action that we're
taking to help former inmates find a job
live a crime-free life and succeed
beyond their wildest dreams
and this afternoon we're very grateful
to have many distinguished guests
including secretary Alex Acosta Alex
thank you very much governor phil Bryant
Thank You Phil very much governor bill d
we just spent some time together
Tennessee
and I have to say my administration is
focused on lifting up all Americans and
that's exactly what we're doing with
this as part of our working families
agenda we've expanded apprenticeships
and job training with delivered historic
tax cuts the biggest ever in the history
of our country and regulatory reform and
we've increased access to affordable
health care and childcare so it's been
really important
and as a result of the booming economy
we're bringing Americans who have been
on the sidelines back into the workforce
including former inmates and those
recovering from opioid addiction very
important and it's been incredible the
success we've had since the election
we've created six million new jobs we've
added more than a million new jobs in
manufacturing construction and steel
alone and everyone said that was going
to be an impossibility to do
manufacturing jobs African American
Hispanic American and Asian American
unemployment have reached the lowest
levels and the lowest rates in the
history of our country it's been an
incredible situation our policies are
rebuilding lives rebuilding families and
rebuilding communities to realize
America's full potential we must unlock
the talents of Eric and Hispanic
American and Asian American unemployment
have reached the lowest levels and the
lowest rates in the history of our
country it's been an incredible
situation our policies are rebuilding
lives rebuilding families and rebuilding
communities to realize America's full
potential we must unlock the talents of
that's early thank you thank you very
much I think you like it it is true
though since we got a pass nobody
realized how tough it was they've been
trying to do it for and then on the
other side you had people that frankly I
didn't think would be sending too many
of the things that I wanted to do Phil
Brian
you know but they all wanted it and it's
something that I'm very proud of and
Jared and Ivanka were incredible
and I think they were being pushed a
little bit also by Kim Kardashian she's
right thank you and Kanye since its
passage more than a dozen states have
advanced similar reforms at the state
level now we must make sure that the
Americans returning from prison get a
true second chance right America wins
when citizens with a criminal record can
contribute to their communities as
law-abiding members of our society when
former inmates come home the single most
important action we can take is to help
them find a really really good job where
they love the job they want to go there
to make it a lot of money right and
that's what's happening and that's
because of a lot of reasons including
the people in this room but it's also
because we have a great economy and some
people that wouldn't have normally made
that choice they've made that choice and
they are so happy I'm talking about
employers they are so happy they can't
even believe it they've got one man told
me some of the best people that work for
him now came out of prison and these are
people that a few years ago they would
not have given a chance and now it
considers them among his best people too
often former inmates are not considered
for jobs even if they are qualified
rehabilitated and ready to work and
that's why we're taking crucial steps to
encourage business to expand
second-chance hiring practices
so when we say higher American taking
crucial steps to encourage business to
expand second chance hiring practices
so when we say higher America employment
rate for former inmates is up to five
times higher than the national average
my administration has set an ambitious
goal we want to cut the unemployment
rate for these individuals to single
digits within five years that we think
there's a really good chance of doing it
thank you
second chance hiring is about safer
communities a stronger workforce and a
thriving economy
thank you
second chance hiring is about safer
communities a stronger workforce and a
thriving economy prison for an
alcohol-related accident that now runs a
re-entry program he's done incredibly
well he's highly respected in the
community he's a tremendous guy and John
maybe you could come up and say a few
words please prison for alcohol-related
accident that now runs a reentry program
he's done incredibly well he's highly
respected in the community he's a
tremendous guy and John maybe you could
come up and say a few words please
thank Thank You mr. president thank you
all for being here and don't worry about
the name it's Greek that's the best
pronunciation anyone's done in many
years again my name is John kupos and
mr. president you know your courage in
criminal justice reform has made America
safer it's made America better I caused
a car accident in in my alcoholism
driving drunk and thank the Lord and
killed that person mr. president and
when I was in prison here I was this
trial lawyer from New Jersey nobody
asked me for money which was really a
surprise in prison but nearly everybody
asked me for a job everyone wanted a job
to avoid crime to reunify with their
families to pay child support and I
never forgot that
and as my journey towards sobriety took
shape I was blessed with people like in
the folks in this room who gave me that
second chance to contribute and I would
go on to build a very large reentry
program in New Jersey everyone wanted a
job to avoid crime to reunify with their
families to pay child support and I
never forgot that
and as my journey towards sobriety took
shape I was blessed with people like in
the folks in this room who gave me that
second chance to contribute and I would
go on to build a very large reentry
program in New Jersey from there I would
go on to be recruited to work down here
in Washington DC to help do this
nationally I've worked with Governor
Bryant so many good people in the room
and without a second chance I don't know
where I would have been I'm not sure if
I could have stayed sober I certainly
know I wouldn't have contributed the
level I you did next was a justice issue
of our time this is a civil rights issue
of our time this is a prosperity issue
of our time and mr. president thanks to
you it's all of our time god bless you
Thank You Jonas that's an incredible
story and I can't tell you the job he's
done so respected across the federal
government we're giving former inmates
the resources they need to make the most
of their new lease on life today the
Federal Bureau of Prisons announced it
thank you John incredible that's an
incredible story and I can't tell you
the job he's done so respected across
the federal government we're giving
former inmates the resources they need
to make the most of their new lease on
life today the Federal Bureau of Prisons
announced that which underwrite
companies that hire former prisoners
we're expanding our second-chance Pell
Grant pilot program to allow individuals
to use their time in prison to take
college-level classes that's
that's great
that's the Department of Energy has
begun a new initiative to inform
American workers including former
inmates about great jobs in the booming
energy industry and that is a great
industry
that's the Department of Energy has
begun a new initiative to inform
American workers including former
inmates about great jobs in the booming
energy industry and that is a great
industry fly for both federal government
jobs and affordable housing something
that were unable to be here with us
today is Marcus Bullock who went to
prison as a miner in 1996 and now runs a
technology company and he's doing a very
good job Marcus please come up and say
hello you're here thank you thank you so
much mr. president when I was in sales
c12 I've never thought that I will be
standing here on this podium so I'm
gonna suck all of this moment
when I was 15 years old I made one of
the worst mistakes of my life and it
landed me
when I was 15 years old I made one of
the worst mistakes of my life and it
landed me if I mom began to see and my
mom made a commitment because she wanted
to understand she wanted me to
understand that there was life after
prison there would be potential days
that look like this and so my mom wrote
me letters and she sent me pictures
every day for the remaining six years of
my prison sentence until I came home so
that she can show me the window to the
world and this is why I'm so glum began
to see and my mom made a commitment
because she wanted to understand she
wanted me to understand that there was
life after prison there would be
potential days that look like this and
so my mom wrote me letters and she sent
me pictures every day for the remaining
six years of my prison sentence until I
came home so that she can show me the
window to the world and this is why I'm
so grateful for what happens when I'm
around the country and we having
conversations around the first-step act
and what we're doing down with these
second chances because even once I came
home it was still very challenging for
me to get a job after finally finding a
job at a paint store minimum wage job
and I was very very grateful just to be
able to get a job and it was really only
and while we were building opportunities
for other men and women to come home and
have a great place to be able to work
with the sustainable employment we
wanted to venture out a little bit
further in in 2012 we started our first
tech company that tech company flick
shop is now a venture back company that
connects families back to their
incarcerated loved ones the same way
that my mom wrote me letters and
pictures when I was in prison we've
connected over 140,000 families around
the country and I'm so grateful because
the resources that are flowing back into
these prison cells using our tech is
building the next generation of
entrepreneurs leaders business
executives like me and great employees
as some of you all's incredible
companies I'm so grateful to be a small
part of the solution because we do
understand that this crisis is huge but
with you guys's leadership I'm feel very
very optimistic about the future of
employment
and tomorrow Marcus will be announcing a
run for a major public office thank you
very much
really fantastic today we're also joined
by many employers who are hiring former
inmates and helping us build the
strongest economy on earth we have some
very successful people in this room and
we appreciate it all very much thank you
very much great job
among the leaders who join us today is
Steve Preston the CEO of goodwill
goodwill employees and provides training
and other services for more than 100,000
former inmates each and every year Steve
I want to thank you for the devotion and
all that you do for a second chance
Steve well thank you very much mr.
president for your leadership in the
first step for step act and and for
working with Congress to pass this in a
bipartisan fashion that just sounds
great doesn't it yeah it really does
because we know that it's not an issue
of one side of the aisle of the other
it's an issue for the entire country and
now we all get to work together to
ensure that we truly give people who are
coming back home a real second chance
you know we all know about high
recidivism rates but it does not have to
be that way
I know because if the president said
last year alone goodwill worked with
over a hundred thousand second-chance
individuals and with the right kind of
support those recidivism rates plummet
and in their place come high success
rates so we need to provide support for
people to get back on their feet to
stabilize their lives and so importantly
define just your loan goodwill worked
with over a hundred thousand
second-chance individuals and with the
right kind of support those recidivism
rates plummet and in their place come
high success rates so we need to provide
support for people to get back on their
feet to stabilize their lives and so
importantly define both for the
individuals and for their families and
it's so important that we remember those
families in this process so thank you
again mr. president for all that you are
doing to be part of a to advance this
important effort thank you guys for your
stories I these are like there's no
better testimony than to see what's
happening here and there are other
people around the country that have to
say
experience if they're given the right
chance thank you
and I thought maybe I just take a moment
so at the White House and been with me
now three and a half years the same
experience if they're given the right
chance thank you
and I thought maybe I just take a moment
so at the White House and been with me
now three and a half years
she's done an incredible job we've been
through a lot together and she's tough
but she's good you know you also have
tough and bad right she's tough and
she's good she's great and she's gonna
be leaving the service of her country
and she is going to be going I guess you
could say private sector but I hope
she's going to she comes from a great
state Arkansas I was a state I won by a
lot so I like it
but we love our concern she's gonna be
going back to Arkansas with her great
family her husband was fantastic guy and
her family and I don't know Phil and
folks if we can get her to run for the
governor of Oregon so I think she'll be
very well and I I'm trying to get her to
do that but I just saw in the room that
I really wanted to call her up she's a
special person a very very fine woman
she has been so great she has such heart
she's strong but with great great heart
and I want to thank you for an
outstanding job and thank you
I'll try not to get emotional because I
know that crying can make us look weak
sometimes right this has been the honor
of a lifetime the opportunity of a
lifetime I couldn't be prouder to have
had the opportunity to serve my country
and particularly to work for this
president he I'll try not to get
emotional because I know that crying can
make us look weak sometimes right this
has been the honor of a lifetime the
opportunity of a lifetime I couldn't be
prouder to have had the opportunity to
serve my country and particularly to
work for this president he has
accomplished so much in these two and a
half years and it's truly been something
I will treasure forever
it's one of the greatest jobs I could
ever have I've loved every minute even
the hard minutes
I have loved it I love the president I
love the team that I've had the
opportunity to work for the president is
surrounded by some of the most
incredible and then in the meantime I'm
going to continue to be one of the most
outspoken and loyal supporters of the
president and his agenda and I know he's
gonna have an incredible six more years
and get a whole lot more done like what
we're here to celebrate today and I
don't want to take away from that so I
certainly want to get back to the
tremendous thing that the people behind
me have done and thanking them in the
meantime I'm going to continue to be one
of the most outspoken and loyal
supporters of the president and his
agenda and I know he's gonna have an
incredible six more years and get a
whole lot more done like what we're here
to celebrate today and I don't want to
take away from that so I certainly want
to get back to the tremendous thing that
the people behind me have done and thank
you so much mr. president's truly an
honor
great person
Thank You Sara and this guy is some guy
in some athlete that I can tell you so
maybe you could just talk a little bit
about what we're doing and how well
you're doing with it right Thank You
Johnny so I remember December 2018
waking up one morning and reading in the
newspaper that Congress had signed it
passed and the president had signed the
first step act I literally did not
believe that would ever happen and and I
mean so much so that it kind of got up
and said I can't believe it like he said
he'd do it but hadn't vividly remember
December 2018 waking up one morning and
reading in the newspaper that Congress
had signed it passed and the President
had signed the first-step Act I
literally did not believe that would
ever happen
and and I mean so much so that it kind
of got up and said I can't believe it
like he said he'd do it
but how didn't they give hundred
thousand HR people across the globe our
companies employ a hundred and fifteen
million people every day and so we said
there's some role that we must be able
to play and instantly it hit me what's
the next step what we know is that once
people get out too often get out of
incarceration too often they return
because they can't find a job these
aren't bad people they're people who are
trying to survive and we can play a role
in that if we can help remove some of
the barriers those barriers that lead to
high levels of recidivism again no one
wants to go back and so what we needed
to do is figure out how we could play a
role the country's human resources
professionals to remove the barrier of
employment and so we're bringing bad
people back into the workplace so we
went back to my team it was of course a
week before Christmas wait a minute what
you want me to work over the weekend I
said yes
mark Holden and his team
he's in the room Ginny Thank You Jenny
we all said we'd work together on the
weekend with my chief of staff and I
team we came up with an idea to remove
the barrier of employment and so we're
bringing bad people back into the
workplace so we went back to my team it
was of course a week before Christmas
wait a minute what you want me to work
over the weekend I said yes
mark Holden and his team Jenny Jenny's
in the room Ginny Thank You Jenny
we all said we'd work together on the
weekend with my chief of staff and our
team when we came up with an ID oak
Richard Branson myself
we had people just signing up and so now
all of a sudden mr. president your goal
your goal of getting that five times the
number down to single digits we're gonna
do it and the Society for Human Resource
Management
Oh Richard Branson myself
we had people just signing up and so now
all of a sudden mr. president's your
goal your goal of getting that five
times the number down to single digits
we're gonna do it and the Society for
Human Resource Management
sherm and our 300,000 members are
committed we're gonna play our role
we're gonna be warriors to get these
warriors back to work thank you god
bless you
Thank You Johnny
this afternoon we also arson and I hear
she's starting to study law she's also
one of the most successful people in the
entertainment business soon she'll be
one of the most successful lawyers I
hate to tell all my lawyers back there
but I knew it I knew her father and I'd
say she's got good genes that I can tell
you good genes for everything and she's
been a real friend and her husband has
been a real friend of mine Kim
kardashian-west
hi it really is such an honor to be here
today so thank you my whole journey with
Kim kardashian-west
hi it really is such an honor to be here
today so thank you my whole journey with
the president granted clemency to and
after that I really spent so much time
going to different prisons because I
really had no connection to anybody on
the inside and really just felt like for
me I I'm at the place in my life that I
wanted to make a difference and just
wanted to do the right thing but I
didn't know how or what to do or even
really what was going on and so after
going to visit so many different prisons
and really sitting down with lifers with
every situation you can possibly imagine
my heart just completely opened up and I
wanted to do more so I started to study
the law which is you know law school
basically in California and my attorneys
are here today Aaron and Jessica from
cut 50 they thank you so art just
completely opened up and I wanted to do
more so I started to study the law which
is you know law school basically in
California and my attorneys are here
today Aaron and Jessica from cut 50 they
thank you
like learning how you get bills passed
and working on it from the ground up so
to get the president's support and to
see it come to fruition was magic and
the one thing that I just realized that
needed so much support that I'm happy to
help and be supportive where I can was
the reentry of people coming home and
seeing the lack of support that really
existed whether it's housing or the
amount of letters that I get with people
just needing transportation to job
interviews to jobs these people want to
work they want the best outcome and I'm
so happy to be here today amongst people
that want the same thing and that really
believe in supporting their reentry so
I'm so happy to announce today that we
have a rideshare partnership where
formerly incarcerated people will be
gifted gift cards so that they can get
rides to and from job interviews to and
from jobs family members and that is so
important so needed and I just want to
thank the president for really standing
behind this issue and seeing the
compassion that he's had for criminal
justice has been really remarkable so I
just want to thank all of the
organizations that are you know
partnering with everything that's going
on and really being supportive because
it really does mean a lot to so many
people that I've had the pleasure to
speak to and I think the auction that
he's had for criminal justice has been
really remarkable so I just want to
thank all of the organizations that are
you know partnering with everything
that's going on and really being
supportive because it really does mean a
lot to so many people that I've had the
pleasure to speak to and I think the
of this partnership with the rideshare
organization
thank you
thank you
right
I think she's pretty popular huh what do
you I can tell you this if she is your
assistant she's your assistant two
lawyers she's your assistant she's the
highest paid assistant Ingres has never
been anything like it anyway Thank You
Kim that was beautiful I want to also
just well it'd be a couple of friends
and they've been really incredible to me
pastor Daryl Scott just stand up he is
some point
he's a religious man but I watched him
on CNN so often and you know I wouldn't
say that's the friendliest and how much
you take apart people like there were
nothing so thank you Pastor
he's a faster 2020 we'll do it again
we're gonna do it again
and pastor Paula white Thank You Paula
that supporters benefit
thank you for right from the beginning
both of them in every action we take we
are revitalizing our cities restoring
hope to our communities and uniting
citizens all across our country
we're helping families grow their
incomes and attend the schools of their
choice earn a great living and have a
truly rewarding career we want to ensure
that every American is prepared for the
jobs of today and for the industries of
tomorrow and together we are expanding
the blessings of America for every
citizen from every background from every
community and every walk of life we are
breaking down old barriers tearing down
yesterday's obstacles and reprieve
Romaric and is prepared for the jobs of
today and for the industries of tomorrow
and together we're expanding the
blessings of America for every citizen
from every background from every
community and every walk of life we are
breaking down old barriers tearing down
yesterday's obstacles and reply' bout it
and you know about it very well and
thank you we really appreciate you being
here
and will not stop until everyone in our
national family can achieve their own
beautiful American dream want to thank
everybody for being here god bless you
god bless america
very much appreciate it thank you all
very much
and you know about it very well and
thank you we really appreciate you being
here and will not stop until everyone in
our national family can achieve their
own beautiful American Dream want to
thank everybody for being here god bless
you
god bless america very much appreciate
it thank you all very much
ladies and gentlemen please remain
seated as the president departs the East
Wing